hey everyone welcome to simply loans
youtube channel
in this session we'll discuss ps1 rank
correlation
which is an important topic from the
perspective of statistics let's discuss
what's in it for you in this session
we'll start this tutorial by discussing
the monotonic function
then we'll want to discuss pierceman
rank correlation and the formula for
calculating rank correlation
then we'll work on an example to get a
clear understanding of the topic
so let's get started
monotonic function
the term monotonic relationship is a
statistical definition that is used to
describe a scenario in which the size of
one variable increases as the other
variable also increases or where the
size of one variable increases as the
other variable also decreases
the rate at which an increase or
decrease occurs does not necessarily
have to be the same for both the
variables
that is to say that a monotonic
relationship can be a linear
relationship such that the rate
increases or decreases for both the
variables
now let's discuss three types of
monotonic function
monotonically increasing in this
function as the variable x increases the
variable y number decreases as seen in
the graph
monotonically decreasing function
here as the variable x increases the
variable y never increases
and the last one is non-monotonic as the
variable x increases the y variable
sometimes decrease or sometime increases
now we'll discuss spaceman rank
correlation
displacement rank correlation is
calculated to check the agreement on the
ranking of the results between the two
groups
without the consideration of normality
or equal variance of data the spearman
rank correlation coefficient focuses on
the differences in the rank orders of
data rather than the differences in the
means
the formula to calculate the rank
coefficient is shown here
where rho is this placement rank
correlation coefficient d i is the
difference between the two ranks of each
observations and n is the number of
observations
the value of the coefficient will always
be in the range of plus one to minus one
where the placement will show the
perfect association of the rank and the
minus in will show the negative
association of the rank
if the value comes out to be zero it
means that there is no association
between the ranks
now let's move on to an example to
understand this concept better
consider the height and weight of the
sample of 5 students as shown here
the first step would be to rank the data
in the descending order the highest one
will get a rank of 1 and the lowest mark
will get a rank of 5.
now we'll calculate the difference
between the ranks
as you can see the student a has a
difference of minus 2 which is
calculated by subtracting 5 from 3.
similarly you can calculate the value of
all the d and then square the d value to
obtain the positive value of the
differences
the 16 here is the sum of the value of
the d square
now that we have all the required value
we'll substitute the values in this
formula where rho is equal to 1 minus 6
sigma d i square divided by n n square
minus 1
where d i is the summation of d square
value
and n is the number of observation
so substituting this value
will get the value
to be 0.2 which shows that there is no
association between the ranks
using the same formula you can calculate
the association between the ranks of the
any given data
so with this we come to an end of this
session on spaceman rank correlation we
hope you enjoyed it if you have any
questions feel free to put them in the
comments section of this video thank you
again and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here